right well i think i'll get
going and we've got um a fair few people
in already so uh yeah so
this is i talk about how to build a
raspberry pi robot arm and drive it with
net five uh blazer and signal r
um my name's pete gallagher i'm a
freelance software engineer
uh i've been doing this for for years
mainly in the iot space
i'm also a microsoft certified trainer
an azure mvp a pluralsight author
community meetup organizer and i like to
speak at events like this
i also obviously like to keep myself
busy too
i'm also a stem ambassador and i do that
mainly because i've got two young girls
at home and i want to make sure that
they've got access to
to all of the necessary bits and bobs
that they need to thrive as well so
um yeah it's quite close to my heart
that is
so uh today we're going to briefly talk
about.net 5
and then what's involved in
installing.net 5 on a raspberry pi
and then we'll spin up a couple of hello
world projects
and then have a look at what the
raspberry pi gpio is
and then uh the first bit of circuitry
that we've got
um in front of me down here that you'll
see shortly
uh then we'll look at uh how we could
drive the the gpio using
net five and then we'll go on a bit
further and look at uh device bindings
and how we drive servos and things like
that and then we'll briefly look at
blazer and signal art uh before a couple
of final demos and some q a
uh obviously do shout out if i'm not
loud enough or if i'm going too fast
then by all means just come off mute and
shout at me it's easier than me looking
at the chat
i'm more than happy for you to just
unmute yourself and
time and chime in when you like so uh
dot net 5
and this allows us to target pretty much
any platform we like now which is great
so
desktop web ai gaming and iot which is
nice for us
we also get the fact that it's open
source and cross-platform
including the raspberry pi and we get
access to the nice new c-sharp
nine features like records and in its
only properties where we can go from
something like that we're
down to two lines now which is nice and
pattern matching on types which is
pretty cool
and top level programs um where we have
a hello world that doesn't take many
lines to begin with
but that gets dropped down to just two
lines which is
as great not only for demos like this
but also um
for people that are just picking the
language up for the first time
we also get some some extra features
like system.txt.json
so there's a new json implementation
which makes pearl james newton king a
little bit sad
i'm not using his library anymore um
just to give you an idea of where
dot net core is i don't have the data
for net five sadly
but at the last count over in build 2020
then there was
more than one and a half million
active.net core developers in visual
studio alone
so they're the easiest metrics that file
new project they're able to track that
when you've got that turned on
uh the other stat that i like
specifically from this is at the other
side where
40 percent of new.net developers are
students so that's that's really cool to
see that
net is filtering its way into the
education system where normally things
like python and c
and that sort of language would be would
be prevalent there so
i think that's quite important that
students are going to then drive that
forwards for us
uh you can catch up a bit more on that
particular uh
video there on youtube so um do go and
watch that later
i'll be sharing the slides at the end as
well so don't worry too much about
noting things down
so getting.net onto a raspberry pi is
historically
relatively complicated it's not if you
know exactly what you're doing it's not
too bad
but there are quite a few steps and
you're talking about modifying some
stuff in linux that you wouldn't
normally be
off modifying on a day-to-day basis um
and i got bored of doing that on a brand
new raspberry pi every time so
i created a single line install script
which just makes life so much more
simple
so that that script there you just run
that one line and it will just
like that gif is showing you just
install net5 on your raspberry pi and
if you've got a raspberry pi 4 like i'll
be demoing here then the process only
takes a minute or two
and you're done you just need to reboot
your pi and off you go
and then you've got net installed so um
i'll go to the first demo and just show
us uh how that is actually
functioning on our machine here so i've
dialed in with putty
using an ssh session here and again make
sure you know
that you can you can read the text and
stuff uh but if i do a
net dash dash info here then
we've got version 5.0.102 of
net 5 on the pi here and that's where
you'll be after you've run that line and
rebooted your pi
so i've also done a net new console and
i mean if you've used
net core or net 5 already then the cli
is a great place to
to spin up new apps it's just it's very
fast compared to the file new project
way in visual studio
and that's what i've done here so
there's some code here there's not much
to it
it literally just spits out hello world
onto the console
and this is i mean obviously if this is
your first go at putting.net 5 on the pi
then this is definitely the place to
start because
this is going to prove that you can
build and run that.net 5 applications so
if i do a net run and we'll be doing.net
run quite a few times
then this isn't going to be as fast as
your multi-core pc
it just can't be but a raspberry pi
itself isn't too bad really
a raspberry pi 4 specifically um works
quite well
and and so we can see down there that uh
we've got that
um hello world popped up and um
we now are happy that we can um
uh run build and run.net applications so
that's a quick quick question i assume
there's no ide and on
on the raspberry pi actually oh come on
now come on yep
i was gonna say are you are you running
anything from the command line then
yes uh there is an ibu you can build vs
code for
the raspberry pi now so you can
absolutely do that but
i'll show you right at the very end why
you don't need to do that actually
but that's that's a really good call out
and uh you you kind of
spoiler that is
uh but yeah so i'm running all of this
just with an ssh session
um which means yeah this is all running
on the pi but
yeah i've got the interface on this side
equally you could use vnc
which you'll also see later and a
command line there but that's even
slower
so um this works quite well for console
applications
uh so not bad so um let's flick back to
the slides and we can talk briefly about
the raspberry pi gpio
gpio if you don't know that stands for
general purpose input output
um and it's not only things to be able
to drive leds and read buttons we also
get serial interfaces like spi and i
squared c
and uh nicely for us we get pwm pulse
width modulation which i'll talk a
little bit more about later
um to drive the gpio in.net 5 dot net
core as well
there's a new get package the
system.device.gpio nuget package
and it supports raspberry pi and also a
few other boards as well but i'm a
raspberry pi guy so i tend to just stick
to that
it also supports windows 10 iot but i
don't
tend to look at windows 10 iot anymore i
don't know if anybody's used that
and it was great at the time but it
seems to be falling out of support so
uh with with dot net five being able to
run natively on linux now and then a few
other things i'll get to later i don't
see the need for windows 10 iot really
anymore
um as jason just pointed out um
you can install this with the cli just
like i did or you could use visual
studio if you
if you were brave enough and use the
nougat package manager that way
i won't be doing that i'm going to stick
to vs code
so um this is what the gpio kind of
looks like on a raspberry pi so you've
got a whole heap of pins
down one side um on those pins you get
things like power and ground and serial
ports pwm ports and
basic io and each of those pins is
numbered
where you've got pin number one and that
square pin on the far top left hand
corner
and then across with two and then below
three and four
but there are actually two different
numbering schemes those numbers i was
calling out there were called the board
numbering scheme for obvious reasons
because that is
the numbers on the pins on the board but
there's also this bcm numbering scheme
and that's referring to the chip that
drives the gpio on the pi
i don't tend to use the pcm numbering
scheme because now i've got to convert
from that bcm number back onto the pin
numbers
and it's just a waste of time so i tend
to just stick to that board numbering
scheme
um i've got a basic circuit that you'll
actually see
um through a camera if everything works
correctly in a moment
but i've got a button and an led and a
resistor so
this is essentially hello world
components for
any iot application and if any of you
have got started recently
this is most likely one of the first
things that you'll you'll hook up
and actually to get to that point where
you're flashing an led in a button is
is if you're just starting out and even
i quite enjoy it now on a new piece of
tech
there's nearly always either something
you know wire up an led or there's a
built-in led somewhere that you can
flash and you know that
you're on the way then um so the second
i've got wired up i've got pin 10
connected through a resistor
to an led you need the resistor
otherwise you're going to draw too much
current out of the pi's pin
uh so something like a 220 ohm resistor
will do that for you it's fine
and then the other side is connected
down to ground then on pin 26 i've got
one side of a button
and the other side of that is connected
down to ground so it's relatively
straightforward circuit
it's not particularly difficult and you
can just plug the wires in
and the components into a tiny little
breadboard and you're talking pennies
almost you know less than a pound for
what you can see on there
pi aside obviously so let's make sure
that we can
we can drive that led and read a button
so as i mentioned right the start i'm
not going to write any of this code
i'll save live coding for twitch um but
um i can switch between branches so i've
got a branch for each of these different
steps we're going to go through
um and as somebody mentioned there that
um there's a github repo for that and
quite rightly
and you can either follow the workshop
and get to these points or you can
literally just switch between the
uh the branches yourself and and explore
how the code's working
so i'm going to switch to flashing some
leds
and if i flick to my cs podge file
then we can see here now that we're
bringing in the system.device.gpio
library that package which is going to
give us the control of the gpi
opens and then in our program uh we've
now got some extra lines of code in
there we're
bringing in a couple of uh usings here
so this
obviously the system.firestart gpio
we're going to need i'm also bringing in
system.threading because
what i'm going to do is flash the led so
it's going to turn from on to off to on
to off
and i just need a delay in between that
so that's why i brought that in
uh the first line in here is that same
uh hello world console.writeline that we
had
originally and i leave that in my iot
applications or a version of that
so that if i've got an application that
say
just wait for a button before the led
flashes i don't know it's actually
started running
until i see that that hello world
popping up so it's just a little visual
cue in the
in the console to show you that yeah
you're ready you can start now
um the next part we do is we create a
controller object here gpio controller
and this
is the part that's going to do the heavy
lifting of most of our applications
and you can see here that we're passing
in that pin numbering scheme of board
that i mentioned earlier again you could
pass in bcm if you wanted to
uh but yeah yeah i'm not going to do
that counting
next up we've got a couple of variables
uh just so that we can
you know if we wanted to change the pin
it's okay but we're passing in
10 for that pin number and if we have a
look at the circuit if you remember
that's where the led was connected on
pin 10.
and then we've got this 300 that we're
storing at light time that's a value in
milliseconds
that we're going to use for the thread
dot sleep down below just to
inject that delay a little bit further
down we've got a while loop
and we're literally just going to send a
high value to our pin
which will turn that led on and then
we'll wait for that 300 milliseconds
send a low value and then wait for
another 300 milliseconds so
that loop will just sit there turning
the led on and off
and then we're going to close the pin
right at the very end because that's
good practice release the resources so
let's see how that runs so i'm going to
run this in fact just
up and enter and i've got a camera
pointed at my
rig and i can zoom in to where the led
is
and all be well if everything works
correctly and we have a flashing led
so i mean actually that's good that's
the first demo that's actually worked so
that relaxes me a little bit
and what can happen is that you're over
practice and then you leave something
like this running and you forget
and then you try and run another one and
it says i'm not doing it because i'm
already running somewhere else and ah
yeah i've done that and it's quite
embarrassing you might also see that it
looks like the led's flashing in a
strange pattern it isn't
what i've got here is i've got my phone
pointed at this rig
and i've got a little piece of software
on the phone that's broadcasting the
camera
and then this browser is picking up that
broadcasted camera so
um and it every now and again it'll
flash and it'll do some funny things but
it is actually flashing a nice regular
pattern um
it's just that this strange rig that
i've got really what i should do is buy
another decent webcam
and that would be the way to go so what
we've done now is we've
we've proven that we can drive the gpio
but um
you remember from the circuit we've also
got a button so let's make sure that we
can read the button
so let's switch to another branch of
code
where we read a button and then we just
wait a second and let that thing catch
up
it takes a second just to switch
branches for some reason
do it oh there we go so uh
everything at the top all up here is
pretty much exactly the same i've not
changed anything
uh and we're still spinning up a gpio
controller and passing in board
and we're still specifying our led pin
but we've now got a button pin
on 26 which matches the circuit that
i've drawn out there
so what you can see though on this um
rudimentary circuit diagram is that it
just goes straight into the the pin
now if you know anything at all about
electronics often you'll find
that you'd need to pull that button pin
some way either high
or low and it's really going to depend
on on your application of your circuit
but i've not done that because what you
can actually do is when you specify
to open that pin and i'm going to open
it as an input but an input pull up
um so internally within the pi is a
little tiny resistor and it's going to
pull that pin high
normally and then when i press the
button it's going to pull it low so
the logic in in my programming is going
to seem a bit backwards
uh so i'll show you that so i've got the
same while we've had before
and what i'm doing is reading the button
pin and if the button pin
returns a false so it's low or zero then
i turn the led on so it kind of it seems
a bit backwards but
pressing the button will illuminate the
led and then not pressing it
won't it'll just turn the led off and
then i'm closing a pin again
so let's see if that works
so the first thing we'll see is that led
should turn itself off
when it's finished building yeah
and now if i press the button
i get an illuminated led and you just
have to wait a second for my
screen to catch up there but that is the
led turning off and on when i press the
button so
that's actually the most complicated way
you could possibly connect a button to
an led
with a 40 quid raspberry pi in the
middle of it um
but what we've done is we've managed to
prove that we can read and write those
gpi opens
um and then you're rocking and rolling
at that point you know the world's your
voice to
almost uh so that's the end of the demo
and we're finished uh no
i'm kidding uh what we need to look at
next
is something called the iot device
bindings because just driving an led and
reading a button is not very interesting
but nicely um somebody else has written
a whole heap of code
that will allow us to be able to
integrate peripherals into our
application without having to worry
about the lower level
um code that you'll need to write to do
that so something called the
iot.device.bindings nuget package
and what it does is give you a whole
code for things like temperature and
humidity sensors and io expanders
and explorer hats and sense hats if
you've not seen
um if you've not seen what a sense hat
is then i'm holding it onto the camera
there you should be able to see me
this little device has got a bunch of
leds make a rudimentary display and a
couple of buttons and a temperature
sensor and a humidity sensor
and a magnetometer and a gyroscope
really powerful little board
but what's cool about it is that tim
peake took two of these and raspberry
pi's up
to the space station and
students young adults and children can
write experiments that run
on the space station and they get those
results back that's really cool
i really like that um and that doesn't
speak directly to what we're doing
because they'll write all of their
experiments in python
but what somebody's done is written the
dotnet code for this
so what's great about this board is it's
all those little extra components that
are already wired up for you and you
just plug this on to the top of your
raspberry pi
and then somebody else has written the
code for you to be able to to read those
things
so it's a really great thing to get you
into to iot just buy one board plug it
in
and you're off uh luckily for us
somebody has also written
uh some servo control code and i'll come
on to servos um
just shortly um we've got
our robot arm that you caught a glimpse
of there when i was showing you the
the demonstration there all wired up so
at
the top of the pie here i've got
something called a servo six board
now um you can't ideally you can't plug
your servos
and servos are little uh motors if you
will
with a range of motion you can't plug
them directly into the pi
uh because they could possibly take like
a couple of hundred milliamps
and a pie pin is only really rated at 30
milliamps
so this servo six board allows you to be
able to plug in a battery pack
into one side and just the control lines
for the servos
into the other and that means that the
power comes from the battery pack and
not from the pie
uh and it just safeguards all the pins
on your pie it might look like it works
for a bit but then it might be that
you're trying it the next day and it's
not working at all
so yeah i highly recommend something
like this
um there are i squared c or spi boards
out there that will drive servos and pwm
stuff as well
but this board i like it just works
so you can see um at the top here i've
got a bunch of wires connected the first
one is the ground pin now if you were to
buy this particular board and in my
github repository there's a link to
uh to one of the the online stores for
you to have a look and buy that
then when you pick it up the numbering
system is it through me the first time i
looked at it you can see ground is
written
near the hole on the right hand side and
it took me a while to spot that that was
actually ground
and then you can see then at the top
that we got channel ch and then one to
six
and they line up with the pins so i've
connected ground there from pin 25 on
the pi
uh next i've got pin 35 and pin 13
connected
now these are the two hardware pwm ports
pulse width modulation is pwm and i'll
show you something about that in a
minute
um now the py's only got two hardware
pwm ports and this the servo control
code
really relies on the hardware of pwm
there is a software pwm implementation
but it doesn't work very well with this
servo code at all and i'll show you why
at the end of the talk uh but um for
um uh my own purposes i've even
connected
a pin to to demonstrate that uh but i
i'll just show you a video of what it
actually does
um then on the other side of the servo
six board we connect our servos um
and this far left pin it's either going
to be on the servo it's either going to
be yellow or orange and that's the
control pin that's kind of the most
important pin
and that's the one that we're going to
use to to move the servo around
and then we have the power in the ground
the ground is either going to be black
or brown
just depends on which servo you buy
so that's good so i locked this up last
night and added it to my slide deck
actually because i was
actually explaining how pwm works with
my hands
and it's far better to do it visually so
this is kind of rudimentarily what a
server will look like so the main servo
block and then the green part
is going to be the arm part that's going
to move now what you do on the control
line that yellow or orange line
that you can see is you send pulses now
if you send
a pulse that's quite short that will
move the servo down towards
zero degrees and if you send sort of a
pulse that's
twice as long as that then it'll settle
there about 90 degrees
and then if you send a pulse that's
twice as long as that again then you'll
probably get to about 180.
now these figures are arbitrary
just for demonstration purposes but
that's the idea of pwm
and i just enjoyed you know making the
powerpoint animation for that more than
anything actually
but that aside let's prove to ourselves
that my batteries haven't run out and
the servos actually work
so if i go back to here now i have to
remember to stop this code because
otherwise that's going to cause problems
so
stop that and then i'm going to switch
now to
the move servos branch
and then we just have to wait for that
to update there we go
so that's finished doing that now it's
cs project file you see that i brought
in this iot.device.bindings nuget
package and again you can you can either
just type it in here if you want or you
can just use the
netcli to do that.net add package
iot.device.bindings it's worth pointing
out when you do use the cli it is case
sensitive
you are going to need to make sure you
get the capitals in the right places
which is hard for me because i want to
capitalize that t so
so that's relatively straightforward in
here now i've brought in
a couple of extra usings so i've got the
pwm
and i've got the servo motor you can see
the pwm itself is coming from the
system.device
so we could do away with the iot device
bindings if we knew exactly how to use
pwm to control our servo
uh but it's more complicated than it
needs to be certainly when somebody else
has written
this iot.device.servomotor section of
code for us
uh down here we're still doing hello
world because i like that
but the next thing we do is we create a
pwm channel
and this is what we're going to pass
into the servo motor control
now creating a pwm channel takes three
different parameters the first one is a
chip number
and as i mentioned earlier um we've got
hardware pwm on on the pie
and that we've got one chip in the pie
that's got two channels
so we've only really got one chip so
that's why that's going to be zero for
both of them
and then you've got the channel number
here um so we've got zero for pwm
channel one and one for pwm travel two
because everything is zero indexed
and then we've got a frequency that i
just leave at 50 because it works
just leave it alone next up we create a
servo motor and we pass in our pwm
channel
and then we've got the maximum angle
that you can set that pwm to so hours of
180 degrees pwms
which is fine for a robot arm but you
can also get 360 degree pwms so that's
what that's doing
then we've got a minimum and a maximum
pulse width and those two things are
related to those
um animations that i showed you on the
previous screen
and it's really about how you set where
where that minimum
maximum actually is and it could be that
you need to
fettle around with those a little bit
depending on the servo you buy the
surveys i bought are like
20p ones from amazon so um i think the
9g servos or something like that they're
called
so not particularly expensive um
which is you know fine and they just
work um there are
heavier lifting servos if you're gonna
make a big sturdy robot arm
then uh you might need slightly
different servos but
um after that we create another one of
those so i've got two servos in this
particular piece of code
and then we do this servo motor one dot
start and survey motor two dot start and
that starts
uh the servo controlling uh the pwm
lines controlling the servo
and then we've got our traditional while
loop that we've got down here
and i've got these two servo motors that
i'm controlling and i'm passing in an
angle now i made it just a little
silly subroutine down here just so it
tidies it up and makes the code
progression work a little bit nicely
a bit later so i pass in a servo
and an angle and then i just call that
servo.right angle
passing in the angle so servo motor one
we set to 70 degrees
servo motor to reset to 20. now server
motor 1 when you see it will be the
pincers
and servo motor 2 will be the actual
movement of the arm
and then we set servo motor 1 the
pincers 250 and servo motor 2 to 50 and
we put some delays of a couple of
seconds in between each of those
so let's make sure that that runs so
let's do this and get this up
i'm going to zoom out and zoom into the
princess because they should be the
first thing that moves if it all works
and the batteries haven't run out
yep there we go
all the batteries are running low
yeah but that's working so i'm going to
stop that before the batteries run out
i probably should have changed the
batteries before i get the demo a um
but yeah so that's uh basic servo
control there so
um we've got at that point control over
our
uh robot arm but obviously we have we
don't have any interactivity we're not
controlling that directly it's just
doing a little dance for us
which is fine but um not all that
interesting so
let's talk about blazer uh if you don't
uh know what blazer is it's a single
page app
framework for building client-side web
applications
but using c-sharp uh it was originally
this guy steve sanderson's pet project
and he demoed it at a conference and
a few microsoft people saw it wow we
want this it's absolutely fantastic
and what they liked about it is that you
can code
your client-side stuff from c-sharp
instead of javascript which if you've
got
a bunch of c sharp devs then you can
just reuse that knowledge base then to
create web apps
which is great you know or reduce the
team even potentially
um it's very much like asp.net so it's
razer
sort of syntax and html and there's two
different varieties two different
flavors if you like
um there's server side blazer and as the
name suggests that actually runs on the
server
and there's a little thin client that
runs on the browser and the server side
just passes
changes to the page dom changes down to
the page when they need to happen
and the page updates it uh what's good
about that is that if you don't want to
have to put your
uh software onto a client's machine
then it you put it on this server side
and it keeps it all locked away which is
great
the downside is if you lose network
connection the web web page stops
working and
and you can't use it so there is
something called client-side web
assembly and this is really i think
where
microsoft are putting uh all the regs
and that
essentially lets you run a net virtual
machine
in the browser and it passes down actual
proper
net standard dlls down to your
application that's running in the
browser so this is a proper.net
application running in the browser
and it's super fast as well and there's
speed improvements coming for that all
the time
so this is what i'm going to be using is
the client side
and in actual fact i'm going to use
something called hosted client-side
webassembly
where i've got a server part and a
client part
uh the server part is going to handle uh
what's coming up next which is signalr
if you've ever seen any of my talks or
follow me anywhere you're probably
just used to me doing iot hubs or iot
central or
something like that when i'm talking
about iot applications
but um i wanted to demonstrate sort of a
real-time thing here and
you can get it to work that way but
really if you want that instantaneous
response then signalr is great for that
um so it adds real-time web
functionality to
to applications um it was um
open sourced and but created by these
two clever guys david fowler and damien
edwards way back in 2011
so it's pretty old now well bedded in
and it enables real-time bi-directional
communications between applications
at the top level it's going to support
web sockets which is definitely the best
way but if you've got some network
restrictions that stop that it will
automatically drop down to server side
events and long polling
um there's more information about that
i'm not going to dig deep into into how
signalr works you can sort of see it
all being well just here so let's
drive the arm so there's going to be
quite a few steps in this so shout if
if i go too fast or say something that
doesn't make sense
so the first thing i'm going to do is
flick over to
um the web app so i'm going to have a
blazer
webassembly hosted weber running on my
pc
and i'm going to let the raspberry pi
dial into the server side part of that
to connect to the signalr hub so it's
going to be like a little
uh piece of code that runs in the server
and the raspberry pi connect to that
and also the client side part of the
application will connect to that
and that's sort of how the communication
route is going to work
if you've never seen a blazer
application you can actually spin these
up and run them from
uh visual studio code so um i've got
this launch and debug standalone blazer
web assembly um
launch configuration now if i press f5
it will build that in the background
and we just wait and that's built and
now we get loading
and that what that's doing at this
moment in time is is instantiating that
little virtual machine if you will and
sending
down the net dlls and the application
and running it and then we get
a blazer application and i've got this
squished to the side so it's gone into
uh responsive mode
which is a good demo on its own because
you get that baked into this
vanilla app and i really like this outer
box experience for blazer because
it gives you just enough to be able to
build off it
so we've got a home page and we've got a
counter
and you can click the counter and that's
um
that's a bit more impressive when you're
running the server side because you
click that button then it goes up to the
server and then the server sends the
change down so
um this is just a replication of that if
you will excuse me
and then we've got a fetch data page
which is actually fetching data from
that server side
from a little api so that i like that
because
it really does look nice and feel nice
and gives you some options to start
playing with
so i'm going to stop that and stop that
from hosting
and what i'm going to do next is add
some blazer controls
so if i now flick across to
the the code view we can actually see
there's three separate sections to this
web
application so there's client server and
shared
and client is where your pages are so if
i go to the index
then i've got some code in there and
this is just html with
what looks like razer syntax in it so
that should be pretty similar
if you've done any asp.net this should
look quite sim similar to that
this sort of idea is slightly different
but what this will do
is bind the value of this slider to a
property in the code behind
which i'll show you shortly but the
reason why i've done this intermediary
step is i'm using something called matte
blazer
and this is a free and open source set
of uh blazer controls
uh really nice actually but i wanted a
slider and and that's where
it was i could just grab it from this
map blazer to use
it there's a couple of things you have
to do there's an imports.razer
and you need to import it at that point
there so that it knows to drag in the
libraries
and you also need the css and the js and
you put those in this index within the
route
and then there's another couple of
things that you can do as well but
that's primarily what you need to do
so that all works nicely so going back
to the index.razer
i'm going to add the code to that now so
let's add the control code
this is also going to bring in the stuff
for signalr so we already had this at
the top you might have seen it if you
were
eagle-eyed enough so this is where we're
pulling in uh
signalr client and actually a lot of
this code is going to be quite similar
here on the client side of the
application um
to what some of us be pi as well because
they're both performing a very similar
action
it's just one's driving and one's
listening that's all so
there's those two sliders we had before
and they're linked up to survey one and
servo two
and there are two properties down here
in the code behind so we've got these
two public properties survey one and
servo two
and below them i'm in this on
initialized async which is when
the page is loaded we're creating a hub
connection
and we're looking for it on this uri
this chat hub
uri and that's on the server so if i go
to the server
there's a hubs folder here which is by
convention
and a chat hub within that so in here
we've got a send message routine
now if you call into a signalr hub and
you pass that string
of the name of the um the subroutine
that you want to call into
so a little bit clunky it feels but it
works quite well so it finds that sent
message just there
and it sends to all of the clients i
receive message
command um which i'll show you shortly
on the pi
there's a few things you need to do to
get signalr up and running one is in pro
and program.c
now startup.cs rather we have
some services don't worry too much about
this this is just so that you've seen it
and you know where this stuff comes from
we add the signalr service in there and
then down at the bottom down here we add
that chat hub
endpoint and we point that at that chat
hub
class that we had up here so that's sort
of the main part that you need to do for
that
so um that should be if i go back up
to our page up here um
in that when we move that slider it will
automatically update this property
survey one and survey two and when it
does that update it will send
this send message uh to the hub
and it sends it with two properties that
i've defined here now if you've ever
done any signal art or when you do do
some signal off for yourself
the demo application will be a chat hub
uh which is why this is all based off of
that
and there's a user and a message and
that's kind of how that this is working
so i've just taken that demo
code and usurped it for my own purposes
uh so
the user i'm sending is the servo that i
want to control and the message will be
the value of this servo property between
0 and 180
and i'm doing that for both servos and
then there's a few bits at the bottom
down here we don't need to worry too
much about
so i'm going to spin this up
and i hope that works
it's going to take a little bit longer
to build because this is no longer just
a vanilla
laser rar blazer application we've now
got signalr and stuff included
but it does give me a chance to have a
drink
for some reason it caches as well so it
shouldn't look like that but if i
refresh the page
then now we get our nice survey one and
survey to
sliders but what i haven't done is start
the raspberry pi side up
so i go back to the raspberry pi code
and
we switch to the relevant branch there
and let that update itself and there we
are so that's done so
i've left the vast majority of this code
as it is actually
but i've added a couple of extra usings
in here so we've got threading.tasks
because signalr is async um
so we'll need that threading.tasks for
that we'll bring in
the that same signalr.client that you
saw in the the blazer client application
and system.net.http which signalr needs
um we create this hub connection and
i've created it outside of the main task
because we're going to use it
and then we're doing the same things
here console.writeline and creating our
servo motors
and bits and bobs but below that we're
um
uh creating the the the connection very
similar to what we did in the client app
uh but we're going to pass in a url to
this one and it's looking for my pc ip
address and this is the only part coding
that i need to do for this demo so
i happen to know that my pc is unless
it's changed is on
that ip address 102.168.1.162
and it's going to be running on port
5001 and
i'm going to dial into that same forward
slash chat hub
now one thing i've had to do um is i've
had to pass this configuration
in and i've had to tell it to accept any
service certificate
because i couldn't get it to trust the
net certificates that were sitting on
the pi on my pc so for some reason
it was just revoking that the whole time
saying i'm not having it
and now i had a look on twitter and
there was some information on there
about clearing certificates and all that
and it just didn't work so
this is great for demos uh but obviously
don't do that in production figure out
what the actual problem is
uh so once i've done uh all of that lot
then i can build that connection
and then down here this is where we're
receiving that message so it's looking
for that receive message
and it knows it's gonna get a user in a
message and if the user is survey one
then i'm calling my move to angle and
i'm telling it to use survey one
and i'm just converting that message
into an integer
and i'm doing the same for survey two
and i'm also right lining out
the uh the message and the user so um
we can see actually on the screen what
it's doing if nothing's happening
and if the batteries don't work then
that's what we'll be relying on
and then we just start that connection
up
but if we just leave that and and don't
do anything else the whole thing will
just stop
so i've got a while loop down here that
just sits there and does nothing at that
point
and at the end i just stopped my servo
motors so
let's see if that runs shall we
i need to get two different windows open
at the same time
it should get a little jolt when it
starts
assuming i've not you know killed my
batteries already
so that should have started and if i now
zoom in
all being well yep
i can drag the sliders and open and
close the princess at survey1
open in closing and i can drag this one
and then move the robot arm around
by dragging that so i like that
i was quite happy with that um when i
got it to that point and i mean
i know it's relatively rudimentary but
there's quite a lot
of pieces we've stitched together there
and uh
this is robotics that we're doing with
the raspberry pi and uh
there's we've been through the code and
although there's quite a lot of bits as
i say
it's not that hard to understand once
it's broken down into those individual
pieces
and obviously again the world's your
oyster at this point you can do what you
like
um and if you don't rely on just those
two hardware pwm ports
and and you have some i squared c
equivalent i mean or you do something
with
like a raspberry pi pico maybe uh it's
got like 16 pwm ports on it then
you can you can have fun and do what you
like
uh it's worth calling out by the way
i'll provide a link to this particular
servo arm
uh but uh cliff clifford i see is
actually in this session with me
um himself and his son have created a
way better version of this arm
that is because it took me about i don't
know five
hours to print this and probably about
an hour to put it together and try to
find bits of
um of nuts and bolts and stuff but
the version that cliff and his son have
created you just get
the screws at the top of this and you
just about see them you just use those
screws and the servos to bolt this arm
together it's fantastic and i think it
only takes about two hours
to print and about what 15 minutes to
put together if you take your time
so thanks very much to cliff and his son
for for that
and the files for that are in the github
repo and i'll show you a link for that
too
so yeah i like that that's really good
and i'm going to close that window i'm
going to close that window i'm going to
even close this window
and i'm going to stop that servo
and close this i'm i'm closing
everything down just to make sure that
i don't end up with problems so if
i flick back over to my slides uh we do
have time to talk about uno so um
if you've ever tried to do any uh
graphical
front-end work for uh linux then
it's traditionally quite difficult and
for a while now there's been
um some xamarin work in the community to
get that to work
but this company you know they've
actually created a a
universal windows platform uwp bridge
um that will work not only on
ios and android and windows and mac but
it'll also work nicely for us on linux
now as well
so it allows you to run your c-sharp and
xaml code
actually on a raspberry pi it's created
by this this clever guy jerome roman
um and it's open source and cross
platform and the latest version of that
was released at unocomp recently and
that's version three
and that uh exposes to us win ui three
but it also gives us this linux
capability uh users under the hood
something called skier and gtk
uh if you've ever done any gui work on
linux gtk will be um
something you'll have heard about before
so i just wanted to quickly show you how
how that works um and i'm not gonna dive
too much into how the code's working
but i am gonna show you quickly the fact
that
if i press this this code here is on my
pc
so i've i've cloned my own repo onto the
pc some this this code isn't stored on
the on the pi anywhere
if i just press f5 and assuming i've got
the right thing selected
then what it's going to do is going to
build the code on my pc
and because of a bug with the roslin
analyzers will actually build
it twice annoyingly but don't worry too
much about that and then once it's
finished building it it'll do something
called a published
hi
i'm going to say
these funny little things on the side uh
but sometimes it works stop that fails
but i'm still talking anyway
so yeah rsync is traditionally a linux
application
but there's a version for windows called
cwrsync
and you open a little ssh tunnel
across to the raspberry pi and then it
compares this directory with the one on
the raspberry pi
and copies the files
nice
hey i'm just going to jump in your audio
is jumping around all over the place
mate just letting you know
yeah pete it just started happening i
wasn't sure it was just on my end
yeah i think it's because i'm building
it'll probably stop itself in a second
yeah i think you might have to repeat it
a bit because of
precisely that
download it
some reason
hey uh we're still having choppy audio
are you sure it's not maybe
uh something that has to do with the
microsoft or any batteries or something
like that or
all right oh was it
can you hear me
i can hear you fine now but uh let's see
if you just
might be better now yeah that should be
done now yeah so apologies for that for
some reason that particular step it
doesn't like it
uh but what we've just am i coming
through loud and clear again now
cool that's all right apologies for that
yeah for some reason when i run this
every now and again it slows the whole
computer down
and if i get task manager up then i get
a whole heap of net host processes being
spun up
so i think there's some issue with with
vs code
uh but anyway what you what i've got
here now is um i've still got my live
uh feed to the uh to the robot arm but
on the
right hand side i've got um a gui
application a nuno application running
on my pi
so i've got vnc uh on the right hand
side i'm just dialing in
there's some stuff that you need to do
to get this to work um but
um i'm gonna release a blog post
explaining a lot of that
soon but if i drag these surveys around
then we can open and close the the
pincers
and we can drag the robot arm around as
well
so yeah i was quite happy with that took
quite a bit of doing to get that to work
so
i mean that's been launched from my pc
and it's launching a guri application
actually on the pi
so um that was that was a pretty cool
step to get to that point
and essentially that's the end of the
demos for that uh which is
uh which is good because that one tends
to break the pc
uh but uh back here again it wasn't
always as
sort of straightforward as what you can
see obviously there's things go wrong
so i thought i'd show you a couple of
those i was when i was playing with it
my cat took a massive interest and every
time the servos now
she comes dashing in this is what
happens if you try and use the software
pwm
so it's really jittery and i've tried
all the different settings i couldn't
get that to work
and also um you must make sure that you
tighten
your robot arm down because otherwise
you can accidentally do something that
will end up with it on the floor so
uh yeah do be careful could hurt
somebody if that thing was big
so uh yeah there's a whole heap of links
here and again i'll be providing the
slides
uh i'll upload those to uh to slideshare
not long after this i actually wanted to
upload them before but slideshare seemed
to be having a bit of a problem today
but i will give you the link to that uh
but uh the first link in there is about
my workshop
so uh all of the all of the github repos
there for you to be able to have a look
at
um there's a bit more information about
csharp.net5
and if you want to learn just about gpio
and driving it with
net5 on the pi then i've got a blog post
there and then there's a bit more
information about
those two nougat packages that we had as
well as there's the 3d printed robot arm
i'm using
and here's the one i recommend you use
by uh cliff and his son there so if you
go ahead and
go and do that then all the files you
need for that are there um
a bit more information about blazer and
matt blazer i mentioned
uh awesome blazer if you want to get um
a bunch of really cool
um uh tutorials and open source bits and
bobs blazer then
there's a little github repo there and
it's got a heap of great stuff in there
and some more information on signal and
you know onwards from that
i've run quite a few meetup groups but
one of them is nuts iot
um and we have some fantastic speakers
but this month coming up or next month
coming up rather we've got terrence eden
talking about the connected house of
horrors and he's talking about all of
the problems with all of the connected
kit that you've got in your house it's a
really good talk
and then we've got peter shaw and he's
showing you how you can hack your beat
usb gadgets.net and that's really cool
actually
he was he was showing me that as he was
working on his talk
if you want to get serious about iot
then myself and some pluralsight authors
are creating some pluralsight courses
to help me pass the az220 iot developer
exam
uh that's a really good way to level up
your knowledge and give yourself a
career step if
iot is where you want to go so go and
hit that link up and in fact i've got a
whole heap of 30-day
pluralsight course codes um so if
anybody wants those then
that will give you access to the full
pluralsight library for 30 days
those 10-day trials that you have on
pluralsight
only give you three hours worth of
content so mine have unlimited so
if you want those just reach out either
in the chat or on twitter or whatever
you like
and uh that's that if you want to
contact me then uh
it's at pete underscore codes i really
should have removed that
underscore on that thing uh that's
definitely the best place to catch me i
tend to miss emails because there's just
so much spam
but do do from along to nuts iot or net
knots as well or not said workshop or
latte or hear me on the agile
engineering podcast or i stream on azure
ish live
and these uh uh slides will be on that
link there that bitly pjg
and dc 2020
and with that um i'm happy for everybody
to come off mute if you want to and ask
me questions and
you know tell me off if you think i'm
doing something wrong or whatever
i'm open to any of that i hope uh it was
enjoyable and you liked it
yeah that was great what's really
interesting cool
okay pete can you put up the link again
to
to your slides that's all i had to miss
that yes absolutely sorry
thank you thank you
was that what you were expecting from
this talk is did it give you uh what you
came in because obviously what we don't
have now is the uh
the little uh leaflets the red and uh
green leaflets that people would be
leaving at the door so it's actually
quite difficult to gauge whether or not
people enjoyed the talks i thought i'd
just ask people and i don't mind i'd far
rather people say i
you know i wish you wouldn't have done
xyz or you've done xyz differently
because i can improve my talks that way
um so obviously if you do have any
feedback then i'm
more than happy to receive that
constructive or otherwise
[Laughter]
i really like this talk a lot of
examples and uh
how to do it and and you could squeeze
in the cat
it's fantastic she does
she could be in another room entirely
and she'll come running in and she'll
jump
up on the desk and she'll sit and then
she keeps getting closer and closer to
it and she wants to do something with
her as you can see she's a little bit
timid
uh but it's obviously a higher frequency
than the one i can hear there that she
likes
um yeah i found it quite funny so i
thought i'd pass that one
and is it even possible
um i believe you can actually um and in
fact once you've got control over
sort of servos then yeah there's a whole
heap of stuff that you can do i've not
played with lego mindstorms
um uh but i've seen it before and it's
it's fantastic has anybody else played
with lego mindstorms
cliff has have you got anything to say
on that cliff cliff's also a fantastic
uh iot guy by the way so
um i'd definitely call that out but um
yeah i got it for my uh my two boys but
they were far too young
so uh they didn't enjoy it as much as i
did but um it's a great toy for me
but uh yeah it was uh it was fun but it
was a bit
limiting you kind of you kind of stuck
with just the lego stuff
um because i found that i was i was
wanting things that weren't part of the
kit which then meant you had to spend a
lot more money to get the things that
you wanted
yeah i'm sure i saw somebody driving it
on a pie
um you can now the version i got was was
some years ago i think i got the v10 up
to done up the v2 v3 now i think only
i think the the mindstorm stuff um yeah
this is
it's quite a lot of stuff in there it's
quite kind of active uh
um thing now um to use um but yeah as
i'm saying my kids were a bit too young
when i got it
yeah yeah it looks like the magpie have
got something on there as well
so i mean i'm guessing it's it's going
to be usb and because it's usb
it's probably just a serial virtual
serial port that you just control this
with
so once you know what the serial
commands are then you're off and running
but
the fact that somebody's already done it
there um then
yeah so just search on the internet and
you'll see that in the magpi magazine in
fact
another great magazine um so yeah but
how long have we got left there alan are
we
we're back at the hour aren't we yeah
you have three minutes left
three minutes has anybody played with
the new raspberry pi pico yet
yeah ah i know you've got one as well
cliff so that makes it even worse
i know just having time having time yeah
yeah flying i suppose take some of the
time out of that and probably
i've got a talk as well in uh in an hour
and a bit so uh just making my sure my
slides are up to
date yep that's well worth checking out
i've seen cliff's talk
um and by all means cliff tell people
what it is you're gonna talk about i'm
gonna talk about
using iot to build a flight simulator um
and
uh and how we went about it and what it
does and how it works
so as well as teaching you a little bit
about aviation um and
how we fly approaches to land at foggy
airports
so you're scared of scared of flying
come along if you're not scared you can
come along anyway
i think there's even a tear-jerking
moment in it i think i had a tear in my
eye at one point so
yeah a lot of people have said that but
yeah i think i'm yeah
most your talk seemed to be like that
it's definitely a feel-good factor
awesome
well worth checking out um on that
respect and again
just call out to the number of times
that i give talks and then people
uh will send me dms on twitter or
something where they've started to play
with it and
uh it really does make me feel awesome
so even if
even if you think it's silly and i hope
you don't then just just tag me in a
tweet and
you'll make my day because i love seeing
uh people picking this sort of stuff up
once i've seen these sorts of talks
um because it's awesome and it's it's
great and it's not
not only just for kids this sort of
stuff um adults
get quite a lot of a boon out of this
certainly if you're a techie and a geek
like i am then
then it's well worth doing but i really
appreciate you coming along to a talk
it's my first nbc talk so i hope other
than that uh issue with it building
there at the end that everything went
okay
and you got everything you needed out of
it and um hopefully we'll we'll see you
all again soon
so yeah thank you
you